à 55 ans jean françois laville est un
homme dévasté alors qu'il a travaillé 29
ans à france télévisions dont 22 à la
direction des sports en coordonnant
notamment les magazines tout le sport et
stade 2 bonsoir à tous j'espère que vous
avez passé un excellent dimanche trésor
de vous retrouver pour un stade 2 il est
essentiel et et 2020 pas dessiner un
autre pour des faits de harcèlement et
de propos sexistes et discriminatoire un
licenciement qui intervient après la
publication dans l'équipe du témoignage
de clémentine sarlat ancien co
présentatrice de stade 2
aujourd'hui jean-françois raconte dans
son livre virer l'engrenage qui a
conduit à son licenciement et la manière
dont il a été traité sans véritable
preuve à l'appui il est sur notre
plateau ce soir pour nous dire sa vérité
merci d'être là jean françois vous avez
des noirs pour virer l'histoire d'un
ordre social à france télé vous venez
surtout nous voir pour nous parler de
votre histoire que vous racontez dans
votre livre toute cette histoire elle a
commencé en avril 2020 lorsque la
journaliste clémentine sarlat se plaint
d'anciens collègues au service des
sports de france télévisions c'est vrai
que l a vu un témoignage très fort un
clémentine on se rappelle elle évoque
des propos sexistes et dès lors une
enquête est ouverte elle raconte qu'elle
allait à stade 2 ans pleurons et on
regarde ce qu'elle disait dans le
documentaire de marie portolano je ne
suis pas une [ __ ] qui était je suis
une journaliste qui avait été diffusée
sur canal+ regarde les équipes ont
envoyé un message pour me demander si
j'aimerais intervenir sur le sujet j'ai
pas répondu tout de suite j'ai pris la
nuit entière ce jeu je tends mais j'ai
pas dormi et je me suis dit ouais bon
comme je ne travaille plus dans une
rédaction j'ai pas de pression de qui
que ce soit je suis libre et si moi je
peux pas le faire et à personne qu'il
fera donc si je le fais je le fais
vraiment
donc j'arrive à comprendre que les mecs
de france télé ils se sentent agressés
par mois parce que c'était leur
normalité pendant 30 ans et que moi j'ai
mis le doigt comme dirait vanessa
lemoine ya m'a dit a mis le pied dans
une porte blindée donc forcément il ya
des conséquences
alors vous êtes avec nous ou en fonction
pour répondre à ces accusations à ce
moment là vous savez qu'elle vous visez
dans ses accusations pas du tout non pas
du tout d'abord avant de vous répondre
allez je voulais vous remercier
ça fait treize mois que je suis dans un
silence j'ai été vilipendé sur les
réseaux sociaux traiter de tous les noms
vous imaginez les conséquences que ça pu
avoir sur moi et surtout tout mon
entourage
je suis je suis fragile je vous avoue
que j'ai beaucoup hésité à répondre à
votre invitation parce que je ne sais
pas si
si si je pourrais aller jusqu'au bout
mais je vais essayer de le faire parce
que c'est un vrai sens c'est un sens
parce que j'ai pas réalité le seul
j'irais
il y a deux autres personnes deux autres
journalistes du service et puis au delà
de france tv il ya dans le monde de la
presse d'autres hommes qui ont été
vilipendés et je voulais dire simplement
un truc d'abord pour commencer c'est que
on n'a pas été licencié pour harcèlement
sexuel que ce soit bien clair ça que ce
soit bien clair parce que on fait
facilement l'amalgamme et on tombe très
vite dans ce piège là moi je moi j'ai
treize mois où j'ai supporté vous avez
été vous avez été licencié pour
harcèlement c'est ça alors j'ai une télé
n'pass sexuelle mais harcèlement c'est à
dire que harcèlement las alors je vais
aller jury répondre sur le harcèlement
alors jeu il faut pas gradué le
harcèlement il est il est terrible quel
qu'il soit
moi les deux fait juste ce qu'il faut au
moins deux faits pour constituer un
harcèlement je leur ai posé une rtt
employeurs à une personne qui n'était
pas son poste de travail
alors qu'elle était dit la drh
légitimement en télétravail je vous
rappelle qu'on est en 2018 qu'on n'est
pas passé par le cos vide que le
télétravail c'est extrêmement norme et
qu'il faut absolument avoir
signé des conventions avoir un poste de
travail et extra adéquat donc elle
n'était pas en télétravail et je peux
l'affirmer sans aucun problème donc déjà
mort harcèlement il pourrait tomber le
deuxième poste le deuxième fait sur
cette même personne je l'aurais
programmé un samedi alors le sport il se
trouve que c'est le samedi
pour
travailler
alors même que c'était le jour des 90
ans de sa grand mère voilà le
harcèlement dont on m'accuse voilà à
cause de ça on jette aux orties 22 ans
au sein du service des sports ou moi
j'ai fait la promotion des femmes ou de
je peux affirmer qu'un certain nombre de
personnes une douzaine une quinzaine de
jeunes deux jeunes femmes que j'ai amené
que j'ai formés
malheureusement c'est que de l'emploi
précaire à france télévisions donc c'est
que des cdd d alternance et voilà et je
trouve que ces jeunes femmes là ce qui
m'a fait du bien dans cette histoire là
c'est que c'est les jeunes femmes là
elles ont témoigné pour moi elles ont
témoigné l on dit que je n'étais ni
harceleur ni un sexistes n'a rien dit
alors je vais je veux dire dans
l'accusation monté par le groupe france
télévisions on retrouve certaines
phrases que vous auriez prononcé voilà
c'est ce qu'a dit france télévisions tu
vendes est intéressant alors je vais
vous le dire je vais dire tu vendrait
des bottins téléphoniques pas besoin
d'avoir fait sciences po pour ça j'ai
pas compris c'est joli mais tu n'as pas
inventé le fil à couper le beurre ça
valait gilet jaune ça valait pompe à
merde voilà c'est les accusations
c'était très intéressant ce qui est très
intéressant dans ce que vous dites vous
auriez parce que toute la lettre de
licenciement
elle repose sur du conditionnel mais moi
quand j'accuse moi je vous ai je vous ai
vu dire à un de vos collègues tu es viré
tu me fais rire mais tu es viré mais
mais ici on des contextualise cette
phrase là et qu'on la met comme ça mais
ça devient en plus mal et j'ai un
problème j'ai choqué je veux dire jamais
personne
c'est en tentant de 50 ans a argué c'est
ces trucs là d'abord je ne sais pas d'où
ça vient c'est ni source et ni vérifiée
pour les entreprises qui l'emmène une
formation c'est le
témoignage de clémentine sarlat depuis
très très fort et on l'a entendu on l'a
passé ici on voulait absolument avoir la
version 2 de jean françois laville ce
soit mais excusez moi si les accusations
sa porte sur ça et si le dossier de
france télévisions il est sûr c'est qu'à
trad je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
mais si on va bien avoir votre avis
là-dessus c'est incroyable gilles verdez
ça va être extrêmement ténus d'ailleurs
de mon point de vue j'ai lu votre livre
je pense que vous risquez de gagner et
vous écrivez un moment page 59 j'ai le
profil idéal de la victime expiatoire
est ce que ça veut dire que vous dites
je suis un homme blanc de plus de 50 ans
comme patrick sébastien david pujadas
julien lepers frédéric taddeï débarquer
avant moi de france télévisions ouais
c'est ça la vraie raison
je sais pas je veux pas faire de procès
d'intention a acquis que ce soir mais ce
que ce que je trouve à l'heure actuelle
c'est que moi je en plus je porte ça
comme une honte mais le sexisme je porte
sa commune au monde pourquoi parce que
mon éducation j'ai été élevé par pas
barbare des femmes donc je g et puis on
a nié mon travail au sein de france
télévisions j'ai promis mais bien avant
les mythes ou bien avant que le
féminisme soit organisée c'est important
qu'ils soient organisées et moi je fais
toujours aux côtés d aux côtés des
femmes pour les défendre dans leurs
droits mais quand le féminisme devient
radical là ça fait des ravages et ça
s'appelle jean-françois laville viré et
est ce que ce que ce que je voulais dire
simplement c'est que
je pense que je fais pas de procès
d'intention à quiconque ce que je veux
c'est que il ya eu une procédure
où j'ai été accusée on me dit bon vous
auriez dit ces phrases là bon très bien
comment je peux me défendre ah bah on
vous donne ni l'auteur ni les
circonstances ni rien donc qu'est ce que
j'ai fait j'ai fait un référé avec mes
avocats et puis j'ai tenté d'avoir le le
dossier avec les témoignages les 10 zen
de témoignages qui m'accuse et m'a-t-on
dit
mais
à force
s'il ya des dizaines de témoignages mais
pourquoi si c'est aussi fort ce dossier
contre moi mais que france télévisions
me le donne pourquoi ils ont fait appel
de cette décision pour que je ne vois
pas ces témoignages à force de procédure
j'ai eu à peu près j'ai vu une
cinquantaine de témoignages une
cinquantaine de témoignages sur ces 50
témoignages 4 personnes 4 personnes
témoignent deux hommes deux femmes
pour des trucs et en fait je m'aperçois
de quoi c'est des gens parce que moi
j'étais à un poste entre le marteau et
l'enclume on connaît les moyens à france
télévisions qui se réduisent donc
forcément je j'enlevais une journée de
tournage à un jean une journée de
montage un jeu refuser une mission au
motif que c'était trop cher parce que
c'est de l'argent public c'est notre
argent à tous et ça c'est extrêmement
important eh bien je pense que c'est
c'est le fait de gens qui n'ont pas
supporté et qui sous couvert d'anonymat
comme on le fait sur les réseaux sociaux
sur twitter sur un compte anonyme on dit
machin nuls machin truc truc on
affective tout le monde c'est facile
mais là ça a été ça juste sur
jean-françois vous avez été viré tout de
suite comment ça se passe ils vous ont
convoqué vous en dirons varekai vous
alors c'est ça c'est super intéressant
oui on convoque on me met dans ses
phrases je tombe de ma chaise et puis je
tombe tellement de ma chaise que
j'entendrais pression et je je veux
acquis et je convoque une commission de
discipline
et je peux pas m'y rendre parce que je
suis malade mais on fait quand même la
commission de discipline et voilà la
commission de discipline se passe les
syndicats disent mais c'est il ya c'est
n'importe quoi il ya rien dans le
dossier peu importe on l'a fait quand
même on la tient quand même et puis
c'était fin juillet 1 jeudi mon
directeur des sports m'appelle pour me
dire que je suis viré un vendredi france
télévisions communique auprès de la lfp
de l'équipe pour dire que qui ils ont
viré 3
3 journalistes le problème clémentine
sarlat est réglé circulez ya rien à voir
le dimanche ou nom apparaisse sur le jdd
et là c'est l'hallali sur les réseaux
sociaux sociaux par non et là c'est
votre femme a travaillé à france télé
aussi way ma femme travaille à lier tout
j'ai gagné toujours un jour accor
toujours
hélas c'est l'hallali s'est expliquée à
ma mère de 88 ans que c'est n'importe
quoi mais t'inquiète pas mais regarde ce
qu'ils disent et c'est à mon fils de 11
ans à mon fils de 11 ans
voilà ce qui s'est passé non seulement
ça se passe comme ça si vous avez dit à
votre fille demandant comment voulez
vous expliquer alors
je finis avec cette phrase là pardon
le dimanche ça se passe comme ça et
enfin le mardi je reçois ma lettre de
licenciement
pourquoi tant d'empressement moi je ne
pose que des questions pourquoi tant
d'empressement
voilà mon fils de 11 ans que je lui ai
dit
j'avais très peur que dans son rapport
aux autres parce qu'il veut vivez une
injustice qui frappe et son père j'avais
très peur kick qui prennent peur lui
justement sur avec ses petits copains
ses petites copines et c est en fait
assez c'est lui le petit garçon qui a
rassuré le petit garçon que j'étais à ce
moment là c'était ma plus grande épreuve
il m'a dit papa c'est pas grave
tu vas écrire un livre
et à la fin c'est toi qui guette qui va
gagner ce livre là je lui dédie parce
que c'est lui qui a inspiré sa le aller
au delà de la maladie aller au delà du
de la peur de la peur de vous affronter
de la peur d'affronter le monde voilà
c'est ça ben je les fais pour lui j'ai
fait pour ma mère de 88 ans qui m'a fait
dire par mes soeurs que elle continuera
à vivre tant que je serai pas rétabli
dans mon honneur ben je peux vous dire
que ça quand vous le prenez c'est d'une
violence extrême par don gagné le moins
daniel vous étiez je crois que d'avec
avec son françois france télévisions non
en fait il se trouve que je mon bureau
était vraiment pendant 19 ans à côté du
service des sports la seule chose que je
peux dire c'est que je n'ai jamais
entendu parler de rien de malaise et
tout ça quand j'allais chercher des
cassettes et tout ça rien ne
transparaissait et quand on lit le livre
c'est ce décalage c'est justement avec
tout ce que vous avez pris dans la
figure des réseaux sociaux et tout ça et
moi qui était à côté je n'ai entendu je
n'ai rien entendu donc dans lequel il
faut arrêter de déverser de la haine sur
les réseaux sociaux quand on ne sait
rien même moi je ne savais rien alors
que j'étais à côté il faut je sais c'est
déjà bien être était ce qu'est une
enquête d'huile il ya une enquête
interne c'est très bizarre parce que
c'est une enquête faite par un cabinet
extérieur
c'est pas très équilibré honnêtement
quand on lit livre on se dit qu'il ya un
déséquilibre et finalement on se dit que
avec vous madame ernotte c'est la
sensation que j'ai en lisant le livre a
voulu faire un exemple moi je moi si je
peux me permettre je te dire je te le
monde a dit voilà 2 2 la jeune homme de
télévision je pense que à france
télévisions il ya eu le témoignage de
clémentine qui était très fort
clémentine c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
remettre en cause ce qu'elle a pu dire
et c'est vrai qu'elle est je suis pas
super ce n'est qu'elle ait eu quand même
des difficultés à s'intégrer au service
des sports et je pense tout simplement
qu'il ya eu de mal à y ait d'autres
choses et que à france télévisions
ils ont très très peur et ils prennent
des décisions très vite c'est à dire que
ils ont dû paniquer et son lit il faut
vite faire des exemples il faut vite
virer des gens il faut aller très très
vite avec cette affaire ils n'ont pas
non plus que ça devienne une affaire
d'état donc il faut aller très très vite
et vite se débarrasser des gens qui sont
incriminés
même si ils peuvent être innocent et je
pense que ça a été un truc ils ont dit
écoutez on va très vite on règle cette
affaire je crois ça je pense savoir
comment ça se passe voilà à peu près
donc voilà ils ont dû se dire écoutez
vous régler cette affaire très vite je
veux que la semaine prochaine cette
affaire soit réglée tous ceux qui sont
incriminés où tous ceux sur lesquels on
a des doutes vous les sortez et comme ça
on passe à autre chose et on n'est pas
du tout éclaboussé gilles on est
d'accord avec moi c'est exactement ça et
tous ces souris entre guillemets vous
innocenté eh bien on le met à la trappe
pour la fin oui pour le monde d'ailleurs
qu'on voulait pas rentrer dans un truc
trop loin quand même pas rien procès sur
toi moi je voulais dire simplement un
truc c'est que pour rebondir sur ce que
vous dites
sur le cabinet
sur le cabinet réputé indépendant
on parle de harcèlement au départ il ya
tout simplement l'inspection du travail
pourquoi ne prend-on pas l'inspection du
travail ce fameux cabinet réputé
indépendant a été épinglé dans une
affaire contemporaine à à la mienne à
france 3 dans les hautes france je salue
le rédacteur en chef du numérique qui a
été viré de la même façon que moi tout
simplement
on
il a été épinglé en disant paru une
enquête parce que il ya eu 22 arrêts de
travail dans les hauts de france il a
été épinglé et derrière des faux
déontologie enquête partielle et
partiale voilà le cabinet qui n'est pas
agréé par le ministère du travail qu'on
a pris pour enquêter sur notre histoire
jean-françois aujourd'hui vous faites
quoi
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui j'essaie de me
soigner d'accord de votre dépression
ouais de ma dépression je peux vous dire
que j'ai sorti ce livre je vous le dis
pour moi pour mon fils pour ma femme
pour moi aussi mais aussi pour tous les
hommes je ne travaillais plus là
aujourd'hui
non je travaille je peux je travaille
pas je travaille pas et si vous avez
vous avez conscience aussi vous dites
vous sortez ce petit livre pour tous les
hommes n'avait conscience qu' il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de femmes qui sont
délaissés les femmes d'abord les
victimes sont les mâles d'abord les
victimes mais moi je sais que je sais
qu'au service dans des services où il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de garçons je peux
vous dire que c'est très très difficile
pour des femmes d'énergie est très très
difficile pour des femmes de trouver
leur place et ne pas être mise de côté
donc c'est vrai que moi je vous dis le
sexisme dans le sport enfin dans l'est
dans les rédactions enfin ça c'était un
fantasme il ya trop de témoignages et en
plus ces voix là et on le sait voilà
c'est plutôt compliqué pour une jeune
fille une jeune femme d'être au service
des sports de ces vrai que c'est comme
s'il ya énormément de garçon va pas se
mentir et c'est vrai qu'à un moment ici
ils oublient que il ya des règles c'est
cyril je crois que si je peux me
permettre je pense que
aujourd'hui vous imaginez une société
comme la nôtre un service comme le nôtre
service public
être dans des trucs de sexisme
maintenant aujourd'hui non il ya 20 ans
moi ça m'est arrivé il ya vingt ans de
reprendre de m'engueuler avec un
responsable qui ne voulait pas arriver
en une femme qu'une femme fasse ça c'est
pas tout rose pour les femmes
aujourd'hui j'en ai jamais tout rose on
est bien d'accord nous on est bien
d'accord mais ce que je voulais dire
c'est qu'il ya 20 ans moi j'ai ça m'est
arrivé une qu'un responsable ne veulent
pas qu'une femme commente un résumé de
foot au motif qu'elle était une femme je
suis monté dans les tours et là j'ai pas
attendu mi tout j'ai pas attendu que le
féminisme se structure et c'est
important qu'ils se structure parce que
c'est le sens de mon message je dis
qu'avec avec toutes ces affaires là qui
ont concerné aussi à télérama emmanuel
tellier qui a été accusé et serra et qui
a remporté son procès face à face à
télérama jeu je dis qu'il faut il faut
être aux côtés des féministes c'est
important et préserver le droit des
femmes notamment dans l'est dans le
service des sports mais attention c'est
malgré tout ça peut être destructeur
quand le féminisme devient radical